It's your choice.
Welcome back, everyone is Charlie.
Kit Harington was talking more
about the Game of Thrones Jon Snow sequel.
So we'll break it all down.
I know there's lots of questions
about what's going on
because there was all this news about.
Game of Thrones sequels and prequels
that they had canceled
or paused development on in
some that were continuing.
They are still working on
a bunch of them all.
Explain which ones were canceled
and which ones are continuing.
If you're brand new to the channel,
of course
I will do videos for all of them,
just like
I did for the original Game of Thrones
series, just like I'm
doing for the House of the Dragon
episodes.
They're getting ready to film
House of the Dragon Season two as we speak
right now as a me posting this video.
It sounds like that's probably going
to wind up being released in either
spring or summer 2024, though
I'm not expecting them to release House
of the Dragon Season two until next year.
But this is Kit Harington talking
about his Game of Thrones Jon Snow sequel.
There's there's rumors out there
that there's a there's a Game of Thrones
spinoff
that features your character, Jon Snow.
I can't say anything on that.
Is it is it happening?
Well, it's,
you know, do you A year and a half.
Yeah. Yeah.
Yeah, I do want to have it.
You know, I get recognized
a little less nowadays and.
Oh, wow.
And it kind of hurts my ego, you know?
And we could see a Game of Thrones
spin off right now with Jon Snow.
All right, We'll do this together.
We'll do it together.
The reason
why he's joking about it
there is because they just had
a convention
where he was talking about the character
and like where he would pick up
next, like things that they didn't address
during the main Game of Thrones series
that they would potentially address
in this future.
Jon Snow sequel
after the events of the main series.
I think if you asked him, he said
he would have thought he got off lightly.
He, you know, at the end of the show,
when we find him in that cell, he's
preparing to be beheaded.
And he wants to be he's done
like the fact he goes to
the war is the greatest gift to him
and also the greatest cos
he's going to go back up to the place
with all this history
and live out his life
thinking about how he killed down here
thinking about Ygritte dying in his arms
and the guys lives
thinking about how he can only
live out his life,
thinking about all of this trauma
and that.
That's interesting.
So I think
when we leave it at the end of the show,
there's always this feeling of like,
I think we wanted
some kind of little smile
and things are okay.
He's not okay.
But it really goes down
quite deeply to Jon's internal conflict,
which is that he doesn't know who he is.
He's never known who he is.
He knows he prefers to identify
with being a bastard,
but he kind of wanted to be a star.
And by the end of the show, he has this
Targaryen thing thrown in as well.
And we don't really see what is
when we don't get time to see where
that sits with him.
But I think that he doesn't
he's never really known.
He's been told who he is.
All through his life, being told
who he could be, who he should be.
He's actually quite far away
from knowing who,
who and hasn't had time in our show
to really center on who John is.
He doesn't have time still, but I think
he's Jon Snow.
He's not John Stark
and he's not Jon's Hungarian.
He's Jon Snow.
He's really just talking
about the simple stuff.
Like that's just the beginning.
The whole idea that
he never really figured out who he was.
They really brushed over that
during the original series
just because they blew
through the final season so quickly.
But it is one of the Game of Thrones
sequels,
prequel series
that they're continuing to develop.
The reason why things aren't moving
so quickly, like the reason
why you don't hear people talking
about all these sequels and prequels more
is because of the big Warner Brothers
Discovery merger last year,
the big debacle that happened with that,
like things were getting canceled
left and right.
You probably heard
about a bunch of people's
favorite shows in movies
just outright being wiped from HBO.
Max At the time, they were trying to wipe
$3 billion of debt off of their books.
Is part of the merger.
And because of that, George R.R.
Martin said that even the Game of Thrones
people at HBO who are in charge
of developing all these sequels
and prequels,
even working on House of the Dragon
are big revenue drivers.
Like all of them love
all the Game of Thrones stuff
because it's a huge money earner for them.
Even they were told to slow down
on the development
of a lot of their sequels and prequels.
Just because it takes hundreds
of millions of dollars
just to get one of the shows off
the ground in originally,
like before all the big buyout nonsense
when they still had tons of money
and they were developing a bunch of shows
all at the same time.
AT&T basically told HBO that they wanted
to get to a point where there were
to like multiple Game of Thrones
series on the air in the same year.
So it would have been a situation
where you have like House
of the Dragon season two and season
one of the Jon Snow sequel.
Now, basically what's happened
is they've slowed that down.
So it's more like one series per year.
There might be a point where they get
to two Game of Thrones series per year.
That'd be fantastic,
but I'm not expecting it anytime soon.
Don't hold your breath on that.
It would mean HBO spending about a half
a billion dollars every year
to get 20 episodes of television out.
The new Warner Brothers CEO is like,
Please don't do that.
Please
don't spend a half a billion dollars.
Spend like half of that.
Also, what's going on right now
is that George R.R.
Martin just literally
has to help them write more canon material
that they would base
the Jon Snow sequel on because he's not
going to let them make a bad show like it.
Where the main show ended,
he resigned a new contract
to develop more shows for HBO
in the Game of Thrones universe,
and as part of that contract,
he has way more say,
way more power in what actually happens.
In fact, for House of the Dragon,
he actually worked with Ryan Condal,
the showrunner, to develop the show
before they brought it to HBO.
Like he's
the one that went to Ryan Condal said,
You come on and you develop
this House of the Dragon series with me.
Then they went to HBO and George R.R.
Martin said,
Why don't you do this show? My idea.
Let's turn this into a series
instead of that blood moon idea.
For the most part, George R.R.
Martin is helping them
develop all the shows,
but some of them he's more involved
in than others.
So the ones that he's involved in
have a much better chance
of actually making it to screen.
And one of the big surprises of the Jon
Snow sequel is that it was actually Kit
Harrington's idea.
He's the one who put a team together
and then brought the idea to HBO,
like, hey, you know,
I kind of want to do a sequel.
Can we do that?
And HBO was like,
Hell, yes, we'll do that.
There have been several ideas
for a Game of Thrones sequels
with the main actors, like an ARIA show
set with her going west of Westeros.
Like what happens to her
after the events of the ending?
The general rule of thumb
is that any of the Game of Thrones sequels
or spinoff series that are centered
around one of the original main characters
from the original series
have priority over a lot of the lesser
ideas for prequel series that they have.
Like, Oh, both of the original actors
want to come back.
All right, let's fast track that
idea, though, because it takes George R.R.
Martin so long to write new material
like we've been waiting
for Winds of Winter for over a decade now.
And because of them pinching pennies
at HBO, it's just going to take them
a little bit longer to actually work
this idea out.
They also haven't said if this Jon Snow
sequel would be a one off,
like it'd be a limited series or it would
continue on for multiple seasons.
I've already addressed their plan
for the House of the Dragon series.
They've actually turned that
into like a much bigger idea.
Originally,
it was just going to be its own
small shows
that around The Dance of the Dragons,
but they basically turned it into a fire
and blood show
that will cover the events of many
different eras of the Targaryen history,
and they'll just continue to call it
House of the Dragon.
So even though House of the Dragon
might only take them up to like three
or four seasons, when they get to season
four or season five,
they'll treat it like an anthology
series, recast some of the actors
and do the Blackfire rebellion and so on
and so forth throughout their history,
backwards and forwards.
That's
how they'd also do Aegon's Conquest.
They've talked about doing Aegon's
conquest
as part of the House of the Dragon,
but they would probably wait
till after they're done
with the dance of the Dragons
or go down the list of all of them
explaining which ones were confirmed
to still be going,
which ones were just delayed
a little bit longer,
and which ones were outright canceled.
First off is House of the Dragon.
Of course, they're still making it. Like,
I literally just talked about it.
They're filming season two really soon.
Ryan Condal, the showrunner, said
that they specifically reference
the Crown on Netflix
as a show that would jump through time
with different actors playing characters.
So they're just going to continue
doing that for many different time
periods, many different events
in the Targaryen history.
That's how you get ten
plus seasons of House of the Dragon.
They treat it more like an anthology.
The next one they're still making
is the Jon Snow.
Game of Thrones sequel.
This is true basically for any sequel show
starring one of the core main characters
from the original series,
Arya Stark is another example.
Maisie Williams is like, Well, you have to
come up with a good enough idea.
Of course
I'll come back and I'll do an ARIA series.
After the original show ended,
there have been talk of
doing an ARIA series
at some point for her adventures
on the Western continent,
like what's west of Westeros?
What did she do
when she left on that ship?
The only thing about the Jon Snow series,
they probably just delayed it
for a little while
and won't actually start filming it
until they announce producers, directors
or supporting cast.
So I'm not expecting them to start
filming this year or even next year.
Like they probably don't
want to air multiple Game of Thrones
series at the same time right now.
The next big one is Another House,
the Dragon based series.
So Ryan Condal,
showrunner of the House of the Dragon,
said that before he started working
on the series right now with George R.R.
Martin, he was actually pitching HBO
a Tales of Duncan Egg Series
since he jumped the House of the Dragon.
It's been an enormous success for them.
They're making like
a billion seasons of it at this point.
What they'll probably do
is just slot in the Tales of Duncan
Egg as one of the events
that they cover later on in the timeline
might be a long time
before they actually cover it,
but they're still probably planning on
doing it within the house.
The Dragon Larger Idea.
The events of Duncan Egg follows
their Duncan the Tall, who's the ancestor
of Brienne of Tarth and egg, the future
egg on the fifth King of Westeros.
But when he was a boy, they referenced him
during the original series Egg as Mr.
Aman's younger brother.
That's how old Mr. Ammon is. He's ancient.
He references him when he died.
The other cool thing about Mr.
Ammon in Eggs Back story
is that there's a little bit of crossover
with the Blood Raven,
who became the three Eyed Raven.
They'll probably cover his backstory
during
a future season of House of the Dragon
when they cover the Blackfire rebellions.
There's a Sea Snake series
about Corliss Valerian
nine voyages set earlier in his life,
so it would be a much younger
actor playing the character.
All the artifacts that they featured
around the High Tide Castle,
and they featured them
pretty prominently are meant
to be trophies that he took from each of
his nine famous voyages around the world.
They're mostly taken from parts of Essos
that we haven't seen on any of the series,
like the original Game of Thrones
series or House of the Dragon.
Yet they've been talking about this series
like it's a completely different thing,
like not part of the larger House
of the Dragon type of series.
Would they probably done it,
just delayed it indefinitely.
It sounds like they still plan on making
it eventually, but not for a long time.
There's a Princess Nymeria
and the 10,000 Ship series.
They even tease
that they were planning on doing it
during House of the Dragon Episode one
The page that Raniere and Allison
are reading from in that book
as Rhaenyra tears it out of the book
is the story of Mary in the 10,000 ships.
Later during House of Dragon
Episode ten, Allison actually
sends her the page back is a sign
of their former friendship.
Like I kept this page the whole time.
Nymeria is meant to be
this really inspirational figure
to a lot of women in Westeros,
particularly to Rhaenyra,
because she was a woman of great power
who's remembered
for doing very great things.
Originally she was a princess
from the Raynor people over here in Essos.
They were pushed out of their ancestral
homeland by the ancient Bulgarians.
During the expansion of the freehold.
They retreated with the 10,000 ships
to Westeros landing in Dorne
and conquering the area.
The Martell's descend from her line,
which is part of the reason
why the Martell's have hated
the Targaryens in the crown for so long.
They didn't bend the knee
during Aegon's conquest and only joined
the other six kingdoms as part of Westeros
much, much later in the timeline.
Well, after the events
of the Dance of the Dragons,
there was a series about the Golden Empire
set in the distant past, long
before the rise of the valyrian
freehold set in this country
over here in eastern essos.
It sounds like it was one of the series
that they delayed indefinitely,
like effectively canceled.
Maybe it will come back in some form
in the distant future.
There was a series set in fleabottom
after the events of House of the Dragon,
but before the main series, Fleabottom
is this area of King's
Landing that we visited
several times on the main series
and on House of the Dragon.
Damon spends a lot of his time there
horsing around, as does Egg on the second.
I believe they canceled this.
I don't think they're planning
on making a flea bottom series anymore.
There was also the infamous Blood
Moon prequel series
that they canceled a long time ago.
It was set before the first long night,
thousands of thousands of years ago.
This was the famous pilot
that they spent $30 million
filming, only to cancel it
after seeing the finished version.
It wasn't that it was bad
or anything like that,
like they still made
a very good episode of television.
It's just the HBO
came up with a stronger idea
that they felt like
would earn them more money.
Ultimately, it'd be more popular,
which was House of the Dragon.
There were also a couple adult animation
based game of Thrones series
they were working on. George R.R.
Martin
said he was really excited about them,
but they were treated
more like love, death and robots,
where each episode had different styles
of animation telling different stories.
It's not like
it would have been really cool,
but this is also
one of the ones they canceled
because if you haven't seen the news,
Warner Brothers
has been canceling stuff left and right,
like I said, to save money.
But of all the stuff
they've been canceling,
the stuff they've been quickest to cancel
has been the animation.
As we get more information
about some of these other sequels
and prequels
over the next couple of years, of course,
I'll continue to do videos for them
and for House of the Dragon Season two.
As we get more footage from the set,
everyone click here
for my House of the Dragon Season
two teaser video and learn about
some of the new characters are introducing
and click here for my game of Thrones
Alternate ending and deleted scenes video.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one